okay there's a lot to this next story
and I want to make sure I get to
everything so the big picture is that a
bunch of senators have been caught
selling huge amounts of shares of stock
after getting a briefing about
coronavirus but while publicly they and
Donald Trump continued to claim
everything's fine
we're prepared this is no big deal now
these are mostly Republicans there's a
claim that Democratic Senator Dianne
Feinstein also did the same but when I
look at the details it doesn't look like
Dianne Feinstein is actually part of
this crony crew so let's start going
through it first of all reports that
Republican Senator Richard burr sold
somewhere between 600,000 and 1.7
million dollars in stock after getting a
bunch of briefings about how coronavirus
was coming but while publicly Burr was
still think saying things like the u.s.
today is better prepared than ever
before to face emerging public health
threats like coronavirus privately he
was dumping stock presumably in advance
of the crash that ultimately came and of
course that stock market crash did
eventually happen the coronavirus
briefings included one on January 24th
also attended by senators Kelly laughs
nur Republican Ron Johnson Republican
James Inhofe Republican Dianne Feinstein
Democrat that gets us to James Inhofe
James Inhofe sold a whole bunch of stock
in PayPal into it which makes TurboTax
Dana corporation Brookfield Asset
Management and Apple of Tim Apple Fame
of course Kelly Lafleur tweeted about
being at that briefing on January 24th
she said quote appreciate today's
briefing from the president's top health
officials on the novel coronavirus
outbreak these men and women are working
around the clock to keep our country
safe and healthy she then started
selling stock but also buying stock in
companies that would do well during an
area during a time of quarantine and
work from home for example buying shares
of Citrix which runs file-sharing
service share file and remote access
service log me in the
fifteen stocks that Loffler reported
selling have lost more than a third of
their value on average since she
reported selling them we don't know the
full scope of her portfolio changes and
Holdings there's definitely an
incomplete picture there she later
claimed that all of these decisions to
buy and sell weren't made by her she
said on Twitter quote this is a
ridiculous and baseless attack I do not
make investment decisions for my
portfolio investment decisions are made
by multiple third party advisors without
my or my husband's knowledge or
involvement that's her assertion then we
get to Ron Johnson and Diane Feinstein
now both of these situations seem
different
Ron Johnson's things seems different in
that on March 2nd that was well into
this crisis he sold a stake in his
brothers company that's a privately held
company the Ron Johnson thing seems like
a different thing so far and then
there's Dianne Feinstein the Democrat
her husband sold biotech stock allo Jean
at a very low price it actually went up
after they sold it then coming back down
currently trading slightly below where
it was when when they sold it
maybe Dianne Feinstein told her husband
what was going on and they said even
though the stock is at like an all-time
low at that point let's sell it anyway I
don't know it's far less obvious that
Dianne Feinstein was doing the same
thing now it's really important to
understand that a lot of people are
debating is this actually insider
trading this does this actually
represent trading on inside knowledge
about a particular company but the thing
that you have to remember is that
members of Congress have a different set
of rules they have to stick to it's
called the stock act stock is an acronym
it's the stop trading on congressional
knowledge Act Obama signed it into law
and it prohibits the use of any
information that's not public for
private profit this includes insider
trading by members of Congress and other
other government employees it has a
whole bunch of sections which we don't
there's no sense in going through each
section but the point of the stock Act
is specifically to deal with situations
not about a particular company
so you could argue it's not really
insider trading it's not I found out
Apple is about to have this issue it's
not public knowledge I'm dumping my
Apple stock the normal sense of insider
trading may not apply but the stock act
certainly does where knowledge about a
national security issue or a pandemic or
whatever you are not allowed to trade on
that information for private profit
insider trading it can be debate debated
this is clearly a violation of the stock
Act by every indication at least for
Richard Burr and Loffler I got a ton of
messages saying yeah but David what are
the consequences going to be I think you
all probably know the most likely
outcome which is nothing nothing's going
to happen
we don't have an administration nor a
Justice Department that has any appetite
to go after stuff like this right now
really really ugly stuff and I hope that
I'm wrong about that there has been a
shareholder lawsuit filed against
Richard Burr you know from what I'm
reading legal analyses it's not likely
to go very far but this is another way
in which you know we talked about two
justice systems we talked about
two-tiered a two-tiered economy probably
more than two tiers this is another way
in which the people in charge the elites
have a completely different world in
which they live and not only do they
live in a different world that world is
increasingly isolated from the
consequences that people outside that
world would typically have to deal with
if they did the same thing this is
another example of that and what is
increasingly clear as we'll talk about
this later and tomorrow Donald Trump
looks like he's ready to say no more
distancing let it rip old people stay
home otherwise go crazy which is
extremely dangerous other than that we
are we are increasingly seeing that
coronavirus may be very profitable for a
lot of people and in many different ways
government slush fund contracts
potentially going to be available soon
to a lot of corporations insiders from
the government making moves in terms of
stocks to
necessarily always make money but avoid
the losses that many of us have suffered
to our portfolios etc so that the
two-tiered system never more clear than
now quick reminder I hope that you are
staying home one of the things we've
done is we've rescheduled the David
Pakman show viewer chess tournament to
tomorrow night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
March 25 Wednesday 8 p.m. Eastern Alby
Street I'll be playing in it and
streaming my games anybody can play
regardless of skill level I will tweet
out the link at about 7:45 p.m. Eastern
Wednesday night you can use that link to
play we'll be playing on Lee chess org
so to just grab a subscribe make an
account it's totally free make an
account on Lee chess org and I hope you
will join us tomorrow night for the
David Pakman show viewer chess
tournament in the meantime let me know
what you think about the stock act
violation allegations I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman if you ever feel like you just
don't have enough time to read all the
books you want to read you have to check
out one of my favorite apps called
blinka splink a' stakes thousands of
popular nonfiction books and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book just
imagine how you'll be able to expand
your horizons and knowledge by being
able to soak up all of the important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic
to check it out on blink Asst blink East
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month
and you get the entire library but you
can try it totally free and get 25% off
a subscription
when you go to blink accom slash Pakman
I've put the link right underneath this
video